aus meiner sicht aber dass sich des
ganzen verwaltungsrates war dieser
auftrag zu überwachen und unangemessen
auch wenn sie zu gewichtig zum schutz
der interessen der gesellschaft wurde
getroffen auch darüber nicht
verhältnismäßig und sie spricht nicht
ins museum ausstellen die gesellschaft
an unsere arbeit legen eine überwachung
skandal erschüttert den schweizer
finanzplatz
im zentrum dieses kann dass die credit
suisse der reputationsschaden ist groß
[Musik]
diese geschichte beginnt mitte september
2009 10 ein internationaler top banker
ist in der zürcher innenstadt unterwegs
er wird abserviert
es sind szenen wie in einem agentenfilm
die sich rund um den paradeplatz
abspielen
das ist er verfolgte ich bekam formal
geschäft der internationalen
vermögensverwaltung bei der credit
suisse
er will die cs verlassen und bei der ubs
einsteigen
bei rené fitzi hat iqbal khan eine lehre
als treuhänder gemacht sie stehen bis
heute in regelmäßigem kontakt zuletzt
nach den ereignissen mitte september
2009 10 kann man geben darüber geredet
er rezension zum fußballplatz braucht
und ist ein mitfahrer mit seiner frau
zum essen statt
und auf der ganzen strecke hatte im
spiegel networks wo immer sehr stark
schlossen ist wie ihm und den hätte
christliche werte folgt aber eher krane
kam was es gab kaum fühlt sich offenbar
schon länger verfolgt jemand ist hinter
ihm her kaum beobachtet
er sei team pro tag lang steckten die
familie sehr geschickt also seine frau
ist immer observiert worden und sind
immer lübz husum schwächen und heilt sie
auch verfolgt und als ganz ganz schlimm
sie sind der erste angst mitte september
2009 10 eskaliert die situation in der
zürcher innenstadt kann beginnt seine
verfolger zu fotografieren
in der nähe des paradeplatzes beim
restaurant metropol kommt es zur
konfrontation zu schicken hat eibeck
macht schon nummer und das sind hier
ziemlich bösartig ofen los und dass sie
nicht einfach so tätig die fixie das
sind die bildung see mit der dirigent
richtige schlägertypen und da hat es
logisch wie samstag also das ist ja
richtig lässig kahn erstattet anzeige
die verfolger werden kurz darauf
verhaftet und geben preis wir sie
angeheuert hat als früherer arbeitgeber
die credit suisse die bank wolle
offenbar wissen ob kan versuchte
mitarbeiter und kunden zur ubs
mitzunehmen
der skandal ist perfekt und wir bald
darauf öffentlich
[Musik]
denn der investigative journalist lukas
i gefährt erfunden und schreibt darüber
klassiker beste kontakte in die
bankenwelt und tag immer wieder
besonders auf die frage ob ihn das
verhalten der politik sehr staune
beantwortet der sus hat ist das im
banking da sehr genau beobachten eine
fotobox oder bronze und wechsel war es
dem 8 welche trifft aus verspricht der
ihnen durch ihre grenzen überschritten
die hand insbesondere bei der cs 25 lkw
höhere manager der transferperiode
robuster sind aber nur zollt werden vom
alten arbeitgeber und nöte fit machen
gegen die interessen von dem alten
arbeitgeber wo sie sich dort irgendwie
eher ausdruck hand zu erklären falls
mail oder auf einer hand 100 zukünftige
oder aber beständig und trafen mit blick
auf die neue stelle ich bin ein anderer
bank und dann wieder wachsen keine fotos
zu stehen kommen dann haben wir das ist
natürlich ein thema die mieter war der
anteil lag noch so nett machen wir uns
nicht so vorgestellt kantig wie hat eine
cs stand ich die informationen also was
hat die alles unternommen um die hütte
frische keinen job die frage ist
gestellt bis zum volk und dort werfen
sie die haben die autopsie keine bloß
neue externe und dann auch die polizei
funktioniert
welche mittel setzte die cs vor dem fall
kann ein um zu prüfen ob kaderleute beim
wechsel zur konkurrenz kunden oder
mitarbeiter mitnehmen
die credit suisse schreibt uns wir
äußern uns nicht über die bereits von
uns kommunizierten informationen hinaus
eric wunderlich ist seit 40 jahren
privatdetektiv und bildet angehende
bestatter aus privatdetektiv sei kein
geschützter titel
es gebe viele unseriöse anbieter die
frage wieso die beschattung des dopings
ausflug ist derzeit das thema in seiner
branche ich weiß nicht bedeutet im café
im cockpit und der dynamik lassen musste
sie gerieten kommentieren und danach
derzeit mir eine waschstraße wieder cs
detektiv sind das den xii sie war es wo
da eine sackgasse und der machen dann
nämlich sage ja nein ja hallo was drei
sind dann ausgestiegen und dann hat man
dollar sein
ja nein das ist dilettantisch sieht es
wirklich detektiv xi kommst dir
vorstellen einen arbeits- wies wo wir
uns nicht passieren es gibt es einfach
nicht das darf man das ist genau das wo
man der schönen reden sei es so dass
wäre kurz negativbeispiel wir müssen
mehr macht
es war die firma in westick gmbh aus
oblivion dekan observierte sie nimmt
schriftlich stellung
[Musik]
wir führen ermittlungen und
überwachungen im bereich verdacht auf
sozialhilfebetrug für über 50
sozialbehörden im kanton zürich thurgau
und aargau aus des weiteren zählen wir
namhafte in und ausländischer
unternehmen aus der privatwirtschaft zu
unseren kunden seit der gründung des
unternehmens im oktober 2010 führten wir
über 300 erfolgreicher überwachungs
aufträge durch
es ist nicht ungewöhnlich dass anfragen
wie in diesem fall
zur abklärung an uns herangetragen
werden es handelt es sich um einen
auftrag im high-end-bereich und wurde
dementsprechend projektiert und
ausgeführt
[Musik]
treibstoffe
immer wieder vollführen boden und wie
lange würde zu erheben
vierter tag und ort bald eine sonne das
ist jetzt der dreck a4 wurde grundriss
und sobald das auto losfahren kämmerin
verfolge mit der ganzen schweiz oder
sogar im ausland sind sie denn und luft
flogen
wir sind und nude yoga einmal ich mir
zwar basiert in oerlikon sich eine frau
absolviert und ich bin ihre kids nach
und da hat sich als heute mal wir haben
und die jetzt wird heiß jetzt muss ich
aufpassen
man mache jetzt unter nachher danke ich
nominiere der windows im sattel und
hanseatic bei der zeitachse sie die
versteigerung sie wenn sie vor mir
verfolge ziemlich als 650 feier geht und
den zeit sie so wirken ausgleichend
meint mache sie und ich bin jetzt in
monaco
das haben jetzt will sie widersprachen
frage haben wir kochen sie und ich bin
der welt kann mich bedankt und die
detektive nicht ändere
in den angriff wieso flug die investitur
beschattung auf dazu schreibt die firma
nach all den indikationen seitens der
auftraggeberin ist nicht auszuschließen
dass auch die überwachung durchgesickert
ist anders gesagt kann könnte gewusst
haben dass er observiert wird und
dadurch besonders angewiesen sein
nachdem die beschattung aufgeflogen war
spielte die credit suisse den medien
diverse informationen zur invest gmbh zu
die firma teil mit dass die cs
vertraulicher nicht freigegebene
korrespondenzen und informationen über
unsere firma an die presse herausgegeben
hat ist für uns absolut unverständlich
die credit suisse will sich dazu nicht
äußern
es war ein sicherheitsexperte aus kloten
der den kontakt zwischen dem west i go
und der credit suisse ermittelt hatte
auch sein name wurde bekannt kurz darauf
nahm er sich das leben
der überwachung skandal machte
international schlagzeilen
eine der zentralen fragen wusste teacher
und kia rio der credit suisse über die
observation bescheid
wir haben keinerlei beweise dass er
darüber informiert war
die financial times in london das
wirtschaftsliberale leib blatter
teppiche tauschen ging alsbald auf
schmerzliche distanz
für den bau von experten der financial
times war sofort klar der studio wackelt
gewaltig eine der wichtigsten fragen bei
diesem skandal war für uns kann der ceo
der credit suisse die anti am
weitermachen
angesichts des schadens für seine
persönliche reputation und für den namen
seiner bank wgz bank brand konzern chef
tidjane thiam bleibt gehen muss seine
rechte hand der operative chef bmw
der franzose ist ein langjähriger
wegbegleiter jobs und so heißt es
offiziell das boh alleine den auftrag
gegeben habe den ehemaligen chef der
internationalen vermögensverwaltung ich
pack kann nach seinem abgang zur ubs zu
beschatten nein
sie fragen was sein engster vertrauter
in der geschäftsleitung alles ohne sein
wissen was ihnen angst der vertrag mit
dem sie 20 jahre unterwegs ich eben sehr
eingeschränkt und in dunkler und er
zuvor durch stoff das wgt realität und
den totaler versager vorne mit dabei der
angestellte arbeiten wollen dann hatte
sich lautern einfach nicht was mit dem
gay ich würde sagen also hat der musiker
wofür eigentlich übernimmt das ist das
ist aber das braucht loser soziale 44
jährige schon immer so dass wir tätig wo
sie kann einfach nicht schuldig das ist
einmal mehr machen schweizer banken
negativ schlagzeilen in regelmäßigen
abständen rückte finanzplatz die schweiz
in ein schlechtes licht
die nacht ist frage wir machen bis zur
credit suisse führen würde erklärte der
bank leer naja zu kunft
wirtschaftshistoriker tobias straumann
beobachtet eine zunehmende entfremdung
zwischen internationalen
wirtschaftskapitänen und der
zivilgesellschaft das macht ihm sorgen
unerheblich dass ich als hauptproblem
religionsgeschichte dass wir zunehmend
habe überhaupt besitzt 2 1 ksg ort das
wirtschaftsjahr richtung immer wieder
bauen gleich viele internationale
unternehmen in der schweiz cms
körperlichkeit so vor der fünf normaler
wirtschaftslage das sind völlig drängt
die welt und das das problem das ist
probleme und wirtschafts elite sich auch
in der politischen öffentlichkeit denn
das nicht wenig wie das 40 wiederwahlen
punkte ein neues europäisches strick
ziehen oder wird unterstellt sich
braucht die kunst ist einfach mögen und
dass ich dann in der weltwirtschaft das
problem soll das kardinal fertigen sie
wäre platz bis zum milchpreis problem
[Musik]
die wurzeln der credit suisse reichen
zurück bis ins jahr 1856
damals entstand die schweizerische
kreditanstalt mitgegründet vom großen
politiker wirtschaftsführer und
eisenbahn unternehmer alfred escher
[Musik]
[Applaus]
entweder
[Musik]
die schweiz war lang ist stolz auf ihre
großbanken und auf das bankgeheimnis
der finanzplatz galt als verschwiegen
und zuverlässig
zurich banker waren angesehene
persönlichkeiten eine elite mit
nationaler ausstrahlung man kannte sich
vom militär war in service clubs
organisiert stand der fdp nahe und lass
dir ein z
[Musik]
dann kam die finanzkrise
eine historische zäsur welche die ganze
welt erschütterte spätestens als die
banker von lehman brothers 2000 auch die
ihre büros räumten war klar das
finanzsystem stand am abgrund
und weil in dieser branche inzwischen
alles mit allem zusammen hin erreichte
die krise schon bald auch den schweizer
finanzplatz
der begriff banker verkauf quasi über
nacht zum schimpfwort
eine gute freundschaft sitzt leicht
die wut entlud sich vor allem an der ubs
und ihre exponenten die hemmungslos ab
kassiert hatten und jetzt vom staat
gerettet werden mussten
jetzt hat er die ganze kultur wo vorher
durch seite wir verdienen zwar schnell
wir sind sehr wichtig für mich die
kultur ist ein und braucht dafür eine
art was natürlich überrascht ist dass
sich die kultur überhaupt nicht
verändert hat die löwen sind
vorübergehend die sind ebenso wichtig
wie vor 2008 ob sie senden von deiner
ähnlichen niveaus zweistellige
millionenzahl sicherheit das versteht
doch nirgends kommen alle durch leere
brady dougan ab 2007 ceo der credit
suisse war quasi die verkörperung des
exzesses 2009 bezogen ein gehalt von 20
millionen durch einen bonus von 70
millionen mit einer gesamt entlöhnung
von 90 millionen franken war buchen der
bestbezahlte bankmanager europas nach
brady dougan der den aalglatten banker
geradezu perfekt verkörpert übernimmt
der seine schillernde persönlichkeit mit
charme und emotionen wie sie sind mein
geschützen darin und herren mein deutsch
ist etwas frostig geworden
sie würden es wohl kaum glauben aber im
alter von 18 jahren waren einen deut
besser als mein englisch 2015 wurde
titan geboren in der elfenbeinküste ceo
der credit suisse du kannst nachfolger
kam von einer englischen versicherung
und sollte die credit suisse strategisch
neu ausrichten
weg vom risikoreichen investmentbanking
wo er ambitionen habe er schon auch
schüler gehabt erzählte tierheim 2013 in
london
der vorsteher fragte mich was wirst du
tun und ich sagte ich will an die ecole
polytechnique in paris er lachte sich
kaputt und sagte weißt du eigentlich was
das für eine schule ist napoleon hat sie
gegründet
was kritiker in der politik sagte genau
darum will ich dahin
der wechsel von tugend zu tieren sollte
auch ein image mäßigen neuanfang sein
endlich raus aus den negativ
schlagzeilen
man muss garantieren und zur sicherung
er hat die richtigen entscheidungen
getroffen
ja zum beispiel das risikoreiche
investmentbanking und dessen geschäfte
mit finanzinstrumenten massiv
zurückgefahren
er fokussiert die bank neu auf die
vermögensverwaltung
darum haben um die shareholder in diesem
skandal vermutlich nicht fallen lassen
die finden einfach seine komik balkon
ist schweizer mit pakistanischen wurzeln
im herbst 2015 wird er von tieren mit 39
jahren zum chef der internationalen
vermögensverwaltung erhoben
er gilt als aufsteigender stern so
unverkrampft jugendlich frisch so sei
der motivator verglüht und das ohne
mikro managerin so schön sei dann jedes
täter nicht die produkte sondern
langenleiten alleine auf der bühne
offenbar wirkte fast ein rockstar
hier wuchs der spätere rockstar auf in
einem wohnblock in dübendorf kann machte
bei benefiz sie eine kv lehre und ließ
sich zum treuhänder ausbilden
später wurde der wirtschaftsprüfer und
finanzanalysten
also wenn wir am arbeitsplatz hat leer
gemacht
er ist zu mehr so hat mir sehen ist
zeigt die sind sehr durchschnittlich sie
also absolut die spitzennote und
aufgrund psychischer not hatte sich
überhaupt nicht aufträgt also tätigkeit
andere jagt und dann habe ich ihn zu
fragen ob es sich schon anderes beworben
hatte und venofer als ruhig und sehr
viel absagen überhol und was ich nicht
bestand haben weil man ihn interviewt
hat mir der junge mann sofort der ist
sehr lernbegierig sie hat immer gerade
wähle müsse als nur glatte ball
instruktionen was jetzt machen der täter
geld immer gefragt und wähle wisse und
was ihn absolut erfolgt wo ihrer
unterschiedlichkeit vor allem andere
sind ohnehin gute umgangsformen
die an fördert kann die beiden verstehen
sich bald schon wohnen sie sogar
nebeneinander in herrliberg an der
zürcher goldküste
[Musik]
mixa sieht total zufällig entstanden
die liegenschaft das ist eine fdp
geschafft sie hat er erworben
und die hat er abgerissen und neue
behalten
er hat gewiss dass die armen sie nach
boris das hat sich denn erst während
ziele bau ausgestellt wo will seine
betroffenheit
aber das ist nicht bewusst so passiert
was dann folgt ist bester bulva stoff
die beiden nachbarn geraten sich
offenbar zu sehen sind die haare an
einer cocktail-party in teams haus und
von 2019 soll der streit eskaliert sein
und dann auch ihre autos an der
getrunken
die ganze seite ist roma trauer legt
sich daher finde ich glaube meine
nachbarschaft street fraktion habe
inneres trampolin auf der wiese für kind
und frau team oder portierung ich
vielleicht in europa wo sie hin will und
ruhe will h und dann ist das geordnet
werden wir direkt die malereien
einfamilienhäuser vor ort vor liverpools
hatten das gefühl oder die ganze dorf
beginnt vor der versammlung die
geschäftsleitung von der credit suisse
hat ihr untergang teamchef wird zeit
unterhalt zurück damit sich aber
offenbar so bedrohlich dass der konzern
verhandelt ich nehme täglich durch an
gültigkeit
auch geschäftlich sollen sich die beiden
in fremde haben
kan habe unbedingt auf die am stuhl
gewollt heißt es wenn überzeugt dass die
absicht denn auch zweite vom tier am auf
das hat er schon geschafft und das hätte
er heute das ist ganz klar
aber es kommt anders kaum verlässt die
credit suisse er wechselt zur ubs dem
schärfsten konkurrenten
und das nach einer übergangsfrist von
gerade mal drei monaten in seite reiben
sich die augen denn das ist neu am
zürcher paradeplatz
das ist ungewöhnlich normalerweise
müssen solche leute mindestens neun
monate bis ein jahr warten bis sie zum
direkten konkurrenten auf demselben
finanzplatz wechseln können die machen
den ganztag eine halbseitige machtspiele
spieler was einfach darum geht wer weiß
vom anderen was genau und wir haben wir
das im entscheidenden moment für sich
selber nutzen und das wäre besonders
beispiel also daher kaum könnt ihr
einige süße formatieren was einmal dass
das ich spekuliere man weiß dass das
schwer wird da immer wieder geschichten
umrahmt besetzt bis rechts zu bringen
wenn sie irgendwo peter willen wilders'
stritten herrliberg gestoppt bedeutet
das dass gott mir als musterkläger ja
aber es müsste eigentlich wissen zu
haben
aber er der faktor der sonne wurde
vertrag sofort wiedererkannt
kontaktieren und mit denen wir keine
drucke nicht die vereine york misst wir
sagen aber wird so läuft's
wahrscheinlich und das hat dann die
möglichkeit dass er so einen guten
sprung hat keine machen
diese geschichte ist wohl noch nicht zu
ende erzählt
[Musik]